an upstate New York man believes he owns
a missing 500 year-old masterpiece Marty
Cober is trying to prove this was
painted by Renaissance artist
Michelangelo back in the day nicknamed
the mic by his family the painting of
Jesus and the Virgin Mary was once
stored behind a sofa so if Cobra is
correct this piece of art could be
worthless into this three hundred
million dollars
yowza but as down Don Dahler reports his
name hasn't changed giving the art world
to agree has not been so easy Don Dahler
good morning good morning it's one of
two paintings called the lost
Michelangelo's in a 2011 book written by
a renowned Italian scholar and restorer
it could be worth tens if not hundreds
of millions of dollars if it is proven
to be the work of the master himself we
flew the paintings most recent owner
down to Florida where it was being
stored to take a closer look I haven't
seen this in about a year drum roll
please
inside this simple wooden box lies a 500
year old mystery this is either the work
of one of the greatest of Renaissance
artists I guess it would have been too
simple for him to just sign it that
would have been nice yeah or a
magnificent fake Marti Cober has spent
15 years trying to prove the former who
painted this painting Michelangelo
greatest artists of all time and you're
certain of that yeah we have a pretty
good dossier of supporting evidence the
tempera on wood painting depicts Jesus
being lowered from the cross by a pair
of angels and placed in the lap of an
anguished Virgin Mary the five century
old piece of art hung on the Cobra
family's mantel outside Rochester New
York for years
that's it behind his mom in her wedding
dress and in a Christmas photo it wasn't
always treated with the greatest of care
if you actually fill up the wall at one
point parents dusting it one day prior
to that I bounced a tennis ball off it a
few times but once Cober inherited it
outright he resolved to protect the
painting and began investigating its
history what is certain whoever painted
it based their work on this well-known
Michelangelo
many American experts refused to look at
it so he took the work to Italy for
extensive restoration and investigation
is there a chance this was done by a
contemporary or an understudy what we
noticed with this is there's multiple
changes from the underdrawing to the
painting phase copyists would never do
that under the microscope a tantalizing
clue was discovered fingerprints when
compared to one that Michelangelo
accidentally left on a sculpture the
results proved inconclusive cobra
believes there are other more definitive
fingerprints the style of painting so
tempera the layering and the pigments
are virtually the same here's the
original Victoria : a letter the former
Air Force pilot says he has other
extensive documentation that indicates
the painting was a gift from the master
to one of his closest friends other
documents supposedly trace ownership
from her all the way to Cobras
great-great-grandfather's sister-in-law
I was enormous ly impressed by this
picture professor William Wallace is a
top Michelangelo expert he's convinced
the work at least comes from the Masters
inner circle but there is no scientific
way to determine this it's a matter of
opinion of numerous numbers of scholars
over time and unfortunately we just have
to wait Cobra says this has become his
life's quest I'm that guy that just
won't go away
we have great institutions the best
equipment they can look at this all over
again and when you assemble all of that
the documents the painting itself it
only can point to one thing the greatest
artists of all time Michelangelo made
this Coburn's ists the hundreds of
millions the painting could be worth is
not his primary mission he wants
Michelangelo to get credit for what he
sees as one of the most beautiful
paintings of the period and it's very
unusual for Michelangelo to have painted
something like this he did big frescoes
that sort of thing well let me ask you
this is it for sale he wants to get
credit money isn't issue but I think the
money would be pretty net he said the
money would not be a bad thing yeah but
no Tandy I mean any Warhol
had obtained a sip screen that was found
in the storage locker of Alex Cooper
that's right there you go
all right John really hope it works out
and Michelangelo was a prolific we know
that